[Música]
en primera plana
carlos cerrado
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
centroamérica una región donde los
autoritarismos han ido en aumento en los
últimos tiempos para ello me acompañan
en este estudio maría josé zorrilla
politóloga bienvenida
angeline montoya periodista en lemont
responsable de la rúbrica de
latinoamérica bienvenida gracia unos
días pascal duro especialista en
centroamérica bienvenido pascal gracias
y también en dúplex desde guatemala
tiziano breda analista del crisis group
buenos dias tiziano buenos días carlos
muchísima clase por la invitación es un
gusto acompañarlos la erosión de la
democracia en centroamérica hoy nuestro
asunto en primera plana
[Música]
bueno pues en centroamérica se viven
momentos complicados en los últimos años
se ha palpado un deterioro de ciertas
garantías como la libertad de expresión
y el derecho de asociación los gobiernos
han empleado maniobras para criminalizar
bajo la apariencia de mayores controles
administrativos sobre todo hemos hablado
en los últimos tiempos de la situación
en la nicaragua de daniel ortega pero
también en el salvador honduras o
guatemala la democracia no ha dado ni
mucho menos a los centroamericanos las
satisfacciones necesarias pese a los
acuerdos de paz generados en el siglo
pasado para dar fin a las guerras
intestinas vividas en la mayoría de los
países de la región y lo cierto es que
hoy esos países del área enfrentan
democracias erosionadas repasemos
algunas portadas que nos deja la prensa
sobre esta erosión democrática en el
salvador la prensa gráfica comisión de
ulloa no apoya la reelección inmediata
del gobierno del presidente en allí
bukele estudia un proyecto de reformas
constitucionales que descarta temas
polémicos como el aborto o el matrimonio
igualitario el diario 'el país' eeuu
sanciona a cinco jueces corruptos
salvadoreños y a la fiscal general de
guatemala el departamento de estado
asegura dice país estar comprometido con
el apoyo al fortalecimiento de la
democracia clave para el futuro de
centroamérica y en este otro artículo de
la revista 'time' se habla en sí del
talante del presidente salvadoreño
bukele para quien la palabra del
gobierno es incuestionable dice time y
quien lo haga que lo cuestione es
perseguido bueno a qué causas atribuyen
esta erosión demográfica que estamos
viendo en varias veces de la región a
jose creo que tenemos que recordar que
en general
centroamérica y américa latina viven en
un proceso de consolidación de la
democracia y bueno y aunque claro
centroamérica es un país bueno es una
región bastante diversa
me gustaría agarrar un poco la
segmentación de córdoba en democracia y
ciudadanía en centroamérica en donde
divide en dos tipos de grupos en un
primer grupo como democracias
establecidas a costa rica y belice virus
en un momento como democracias
incipientes todavía en un proceso de
democratización que después nicarao el
salvador y guatemala y justamente es en
este grupo en que vamos a centrarnos
y para poner un poco como tú a tu
pregunta las causas principales para mí
es la figura de este nuevo caudillo
moderno que puede representar justamente
perfectamente booker además de la
violación de derechos fundamentales
entre ellos la desapariciones forzadas
en nicaragua y por último la
concentración del poder el intento de no
separar los poderes también en el
salvador y me parece también importante
remarcar ciertas investigaciones que se
han hecho en el tema por ejemplo del
trono sobre la oración la erosión por
autocrítica ción es decir en niveles
hasta llegar a niveles de erosión de la
democratización hasta llegar a una
instalación instauración de régimen
autoritario en el link que ha pasado en
los últimos años en la región para que
estos proyectos populistas hayan
avanzado qué es lo que primero
efectivamente es una democracia muy
joven son democracias muy jóvenes que
están en proceso pero además quiero
subrayar que no todo es lineal o sea no
es que desde los acuerdos de paz esté
que se han firmado en los años este
principio de los 90 este se ha visto un
aire en constante por ejemplo está el
ejemplo de guatemala donde hubo una
experiencia muy interesante que fue
única
creo que mundialmente que fue la
comisión internacional contra la
impunidad en guatemala cicig este que
fue creada conjuntamente con la onu y
con el ministerio público de guatemala
que fue muy muy positivo este logro
realmente funciona muy bien logró
desmantelar unas 70 estructuras
criminales y logró hacer condenar unas
400 personas bajo el índice de violencia
este y fue realmente muy positivo pero
no logró este perdurar porque lo que se
llamó el pacto de corruptos que son los
que siguen este teniendo el poder en
guatemala no dejo que esto perdurará y
esto fue más o menos en toda la región
hubo esos intentos de lucha contra de la
impunidad este que este heredados e
impunidad de heredada de la de las
guerras civiles este que lamentablemente
en este momento están este volviendo a
tener el poder este y que no dejaron que
esas experiencias realmente perduran
entonces se ven en nuestros últimos días
un retroceso es bastante brutal en
guatemala en honduras en el salvador por
supuesto en nicaragua también está en la
lucha anti corrupción y en la lucha
contra la impunidad vasca duro pues
diría más que todo la fuerte desilusión
desilusión en un proceso histórico en
los años 80 las guerras civiles
impactaron la región las poblaciones
tenían ilusión con la esperanza de que
la paz que llegó en los años 80 iba a
atraer justamente democracia democracia
democracia seguridad democracia desde
los años 70 en todas las salsas y
finalmente la paz podía ser la solución
estaremos en un proceso en el cual se
estaba hablando del fin de la historia
y finalmente la distribución está al
gran dibujo de la historia desilusión
frente a causas la corrupción el aumento
de la violencia la violencia civil las
marras ya están inscritas en el esquema
y obviamente una oferta internacional
nueva alternativa que introduce en un
relativismo sobre el entendimiento de
los valores democráticos todo eso llega
a los autoritarismos de hoy vamos a
irnos en este punto hasta guatemala con
el analista del crisis group de tiziano
breda tiziano podemos considerar
centroamérica una especie de laboratorio
de regímenes híbridos que combinan las
urnas con el autoritarismo
lo que me parece pero curioso o peculiar
de centroamérica es esta especie de
juego de espejos en la región en donde
los diferentes gobiernos se es como se
intercambiarán buenas prácticas entre
comillas
sobre como qué medidas hace tomar y
cuando para efectivamente asegurar la
concentración del poder y la
perpetuación en el poder
y me parece que últimamente esto se está
extendiendo también a la cómo responder
a presiones internas y externas en
términos de de narrativas y de medidas
para rechazar precisamente esta presión
esto es lo que me parece que es más
es peculiar en la región
si hay un dato que refleja esta
preocupación es el siguiente el sexto
informe del estado de la región aborda
en uno de sus capítulos lo que denomina
perfiles de apoyo a la democracia y
entre los hallazgos indica que en cuatro
de los ocho países analizados que
incluyen panamá y república dominicana
el perfil de quienes se adhieren con la
democracia como mejor forma de gobierno
es menos del 10 por ciento no sé si esta
falta de adhesión a la democracia en
algunos países ya comenzó a ser muy
preocupante menos del 10% mari jose sí
por supuesto es bastante preocupante y
además agregarle el hecho de la pandemia
debido a lakovic además la crisis
económica debido a la pandemia y pues el
clásico flujo migratorio hacia eeuu y
pues todo esto ayuda a una erosión
democrática y como dice pascal a una a
una una defraudación de las expectativas
de los ciudadanos es decir que la
democracia en centroamérica como
conclusión no ha traído más demócratas
definitivamente el resultado hoy lo
estamos viendo creo que realmente eso se
perdió los objetivos se perdieron a raíz
de los años el sentido de los valores y
diría es un beneficio por supuesto hoy
al aumento de los nuevos
nacionalismos en centroamérica una
región diversa con varios países pero
con un aumento del nacionalismo como
proceso de unión en los varios países y
eso por supuesto procure una víctima en
la integración regional donde está el
proceso de integración de centroamérica
donde está hoy en día el sistema de
integración centroamericano que hay
callado totalmente caído y callado
comentaba antes manejo se la clave de la
pandemia angelina pandemia servido
también de coartada para estas derivas
autoritarias nuestros dos últimos años
por ejemplo nombra bastante es el caso
de guatemala que lo conoces bien como
estos dos años ha ido peor y bueno en
todos los países se ha usado la pandemia
este
y tomar medidas muy controvertidas para
impedir este manifestaciones
concentraciones en guatemala por ejemplo
últimamente se han prohibido
manifestaciones oficialmente para evitar
las contaminaciones pero justamente
llama la atención que haya sido justo en
momentos en que la sociedad civil estaba
llamando nuevamente a salir a la calle a
éste para protestar contra la
destitución del jefe de la fiscalía
contra la impunidad con francisco
sandoval este que era el único legado
justamente que quedaba de la cicig de la
comisión de la que hablaba antes este
bueno ni que hablar de nicaragua por
supuesto que ahora prohibió todos los
mítines electorales en vistas a las
elecciones del 7 de noviembre cuando en
el 2020 rosario murillo la
vicepresidenta y esposa de daniel ortega
este había al contrario organizado
manifestaciones masivas una de las
cuales éste había llamado el amor en
tiempos del coi 19 que era justamente un
llamado a luchar contra la epidemia con
amor este y eran concentraciones de
gente obviamente sin una mascarilla
entonces y ahora el hecho de que
prohíban los mítines electorales es
bastante irónico pero quería volver
sobre el tema de la democracia perdón
hay que entender también lo que ver lo
que entendemos por democracia el tema y
yo creo que es algo que se puede
generalizar al resto de latinoamérica es
que se presentó a la democracia como el
derecho a poder expresar sus ideas sin
ser encarcelados y en este ser torturado
sin ser desaparecido y elegir a los
gobernantes en elecciones limpias pero
también es lo que vio la población es
que la democracia no trajo las
necesidades
básicas estés satisfechas no acceso a la
educación pública no hay acceso a la
salud pública no hay acceso al agua en
guatemala la recaudación impositiva por
ejemplo representa el 13 por ciento del
pib en la remesa representa del 15% que
son mucho más ósea que la democracia no
significó una mejora en la calidad de
vida de la gente por eso creo también
que la gente no lo asocia con algo tan
positivo no mejor así además el factor
de la corrupción que ya habían nombrado
varios de nuestros invitados le quiero
preguntar a tiziano breda desde
guatemala y explicar esos fenómenos con
el prisma de la corrupción no sé si lo
podemos definir como o si es la clave y
alimenta una cierta desconfianza
ciudadana hacia las instituciones hacia
los representantes hacia el sistema
político democrático mismo que por un
lado facilitan la llegada de líderes
populistas
mesiánicos y antisistema y por el otro
básicamente disminuye el costo político
interno y aumenta la aceptación por así
decirlo de hace medidas que
efectivamente menoscaban la separación
de poder y el estado de derecho y por el
otro lado quizás de manera más directa
aún
la corrupción establece estas estas
redes clientelares y estos mecanismos de
favoritismos
que hacen que los funcionarios electos o
nombrados en diferentes ramas del estado
les digan más a los poderes fácticos
o sean esos políticos económicos
militares de otra naturaleza por estar
en donde están que efectivamente pues al
estado mismo y esto los hace más
vulnerables o quizás acomode antes hacia
la helada las
decisiones y acciones que efectivamente
3 consolidan un sistema un poco más
autoritario
vamos a hacer una breve pausa y
enseguida comentamos todo lo que nos
está diciendo tiziano y hablamos también
de la corrupción como mal social en
centroamérica será vuelta de pausa
[Música]
france24 en español pasa 24 horas de
difusión diaria 24 horas para informarse
de toda la actualidad de américa latina
y el mundo todos los días desde el
terreno a través de nuestros noticieros
y programas hablamos con los dirigentes
del continente y también de los que
hacen la actualidad política y económica
artística y cultural para ofrecerles una
información incompleta del mundo que
confronta a todos los puntos de vista
nuestras redacciones en américa latina y
en francia trabajan en estrecha
colaboración para estar siempre presente
en todos los eventos importantes y
proponerles una mirada diferente
france24 en español ahora
liberté égalité actual y d
i
[Música]
por d
bienvenidos a las noticias
ah
amargas y café
un bar casi 99 millones de ustedes nos
siguen cada semana en france 24 su cromo
gracias yo con fernandes min exclusivas
muchas gracias
su granada deje de gentes con sean penn
que me significa
liberté égalité actual y t
especial después de 16 años como
canciller angela merkel deja el poder en
alemania los socialdemócratas los
demócrata cristianos de merkel o los
verdes quien ganará las legislativas del
próximo 26 de septiembre
importancia tendrán temas como la
ecología la política exterior o el
manejo de la crisis del cob y encuentre
las respuestas a estas y otras preguntas
en nuestra cobertura especial desde
berlín
bilbao en france 24 y france 24 puntocom
en primera plana esta semana hablando de
la erosión democrática en centroamérica
lo hacemos con la politóloga maría josé
zorrilla la periodista angeline montoya
del diario le monde pascal duro analista
especialista en centroamérica y del y
también con el analista el crisis group
desde guatemala tiziano breda una
característica propia de los
autoritarismos pues es la persecución al
que piensa diferente lo vemos con ortega
nicaragua pero también con bukle en el
salvador tanto la oposición como los
medios de comunicación lo hemos visto en
estos días con el diario la prensa en
nicaragua obligado a despedir a la mitad
de la plantilla por la persecución de
ortega que formas tienen estas
persecuciones en centroamérica podemos
los ejemplos que quieran tanto el
salvador guatemala puede poder puedan
el ejemplo que quieran cómo se
hacen estas estas persecuciones sobre
todo a los medios para el cierre de los
espacios de expresión
directos
ahoga económicamente se ahogan por
múltiples vías no diría eso se inscribe
en en algo es decir el uso de la
violencia violencia que sea en materias
ya lo vimos en nicaragua
con la represión de las manifestaciones
más de 340 muertos no eso tiene un
significado pero a la vez este cierre
entonces de la ex de expresión y
obviamente un aspecto retórico el uso de
la mano dura hoy en día
política en centroamérica es la nueva
regla y en qué consiste es la definición
de un nuevo esquema político tanto como
en los años 80 que era hablábamos de la
liberación teología la liberación a etc
después del éxito y de la presentación
de una visión liberal como ya la
solución a todos los problemas hoy en
día es el uso de esa mano dura que
podría ser el borrador de los esquemas y
la creación de un nuevo esquema de
funcionamiento es por cierto lo que está
diciendo en allí bukele hablando de
nueva república y de verdadera
independencia de centroamérica hoy en
día
[Música]
en guatemala en el salvador sobre todo
hay una particularidad en estos últimos
años que es la persecución contra la
justicia contra los jueces
independientes este que es lo que han
hecho exactamente guatemala en el
salvador en los últimos meses incluso y
bueno a guatemala con el fin de la si
sigue esa famosa comisión contra la
impunidad y este también por ejemplo
este año lo que se hizo lo primero que
hizo esta
edición las autoridades fue no esté es
juramentar a una de las magistradas de
la corte constitucional gloria porras
que estaba bueno que hizo tomó algunas
decisiones en contra del gobierno este
que se tuvo que exiliar a eeuu este hay
un montón de jueces independientes y
magistrados guatemaltecos que están
exiliados en eeuu el último es cuán
francisco sandoval que era el fiscal de
la fes y de la fiscalía contra la
impunidad están exiliados hoy en día en
eeuu hay un como diez jueces y
magistrados exiliados y en el salvador
el primero de mayo la primera esta
decisión a la hora de asumir las nuevas
legislativa esté dominada por el partido
de buque de nuevas ideas este ha sido
destituir a los magistrados de la sala
constitucional que se habían opuesto a
que habían tomado medidas también
durante la pandemia justamente contra
este medidas de bucle y destituir al
fiscal general que estaba empezando a
investigar a abrir investigaciones
contra este gente de ministros y gente
cercana a abu que él o sea hay juez
también jueces independientes que están
tratando de trabajar y que no pueden y
que están imposibilitando de trabajar
realmente está está estos ataques contra
la justicia independiente es uno de los
mayores ataques este contra el estado de
derecho de los últimos meses y luego
está el papel de eeuu con las sanciones
del departamento de estado los le antes
en titulares el departamento de estado
eeuu dice que está que su compromiso con
la democracia en la región pero
lógicamente este asunto me dejó se no lo
podemos desligar de que es un asunto
central para controlar los flujos
migratorios para eeuu claro carlos
exactamente como mencionas recordemos
que eeuu es receptor de grandes flujos
desde hace muchísimo tiempo de la parte
de centroamérica y en el año pasado en
2020 se en la frontera sur de eeuu se
recibieron 170 mil personas
indocumentadas provenientes de guatemala
y entre las cuales 19 mil personas serán
niños solos y claro también con el
cambio cambio de gobierno cambian
también las políticas migratorias y
claro ahora con la inmediata
administración bay de una visita como
recordaremos de kamala harris el año
pasado en méxico y guatemala y esto eso
tiene mucha mucha carga política y mucha
carga simbólica porque pues justamente
visita países aliados o con los que
ellos quieren entablar ciertas
relaciones y pues a través de ayudas en
ayudas económicas para el desarrollo de
la región y sin embargo kamala harris
también se expresó su preocupación por
las por las por la región por ya que
tiene ciertos países tienen tendencias
autoritarias como ya sabemos cómo es el
salvador
honduras luego vamos a hablar de esas
protestas que hemos visto en semanas
atrás en el salvador le quiere preguntar
a pascal quienes quienes estaban
saliendo a la calle pero antes le voy a
preguntar a tiziano breda desde
guatemala desde el crysis grupo no buque
el señor dice no sigue los pasos un poco
de ortega constitucional a carta por las
en las instituciones desprestigio de
movimientos de protesta
cuál es su particularidad
bueno efectivamente
lo que le ha mirado de cerca en lo que
ha ocurrido en los últimos años en
honduras en nicaragua y está siguiendo
en alguna manera los ciertos pasos que
han tomado con orlando y tener a ortega
pero me parece que hay tres elementos
que destacan o qué destacaría yo de la
trayectoria del buque el primero la
rapidez con la que ha emergido como
figura política y con la que está
efectivamente
desbaratando las instituciones y los
pesos y contrapesos democráticos en el
salvador y en segundo lugar la capacidad
comunicacional de este presidente que ha
sabido
presentar muchas de esas acciones como
necesarias y por lo tanto ha sabido
mantener un apoyo popular realmente alto
y en 3er lugar y creo que quizás esto
puede hacer también un poco más
problemático y preocupante y es que
otros en la región también desarrollado
a lo largo de los años un sistema
personalista
y de gestión familiar
del estado realmente daniel ortega en
nicaragua
el proyecto político del buque ley se ha
basado en ello se ha creado a partir de
ello y a diferencia de los demás
que no le debe a él su partido sus bases
sus representantes por estar donde está
sino que es todo lo contrario son los
representantes y los demás funcionarios
que deben a la popularidad de lo que le
ha por los resultados que se han
obtenido en las elecciones y por sus
nombramientos y esto creo que los hacen
más
dóciles más leales y aplasta con lo que
puede ser un proceso de oposición
interna o de crítica interna dentro del
estado del gobierno salvadoreño y esto
es claramente más preocupante gracias
estaba apuntando a estos factores muy
interesantes algunos paralelismos de
otras diferencias es decir se se parece
como proyecto personalista a otros
líderes que ha tenido la región pero la
rapidez la forma de comunicación y la
independencia de la formación política
la que no debe nada vemos ahí esos
paralelismos
/ bucle y otros no buscar y eso recuerda
la diversidad de centroamérica cada país
tiene su propia historia tiene sus
propios mecanismos daniel ortega fue el
líder que sabemos en el censo 80 en allí
bukele a pesar de todo tiene ya un
recorrido político fue alcalde de la
capital durante años fue candidato
presidencial con bajo la bandera del
partido ghana cuyo fundador está a la
cárcel todavía un ex presidente que robó
más de 300 millones de dólares entonces
creo que bukele es el hiper pragmatismo
es el y pragmatismo porque si juega con
con eso y como bien ha sido dicho hay
una fuerza de comunicación pero también
de deshumanización el hiper pragmatismo
está encerrado en una forma de simbólica
pero esa simbólica la nueva
independencia
hoy en día vamos a volver como el modelo
hiper práctico pragmático de
centroamérica está picados
aplicándose con una para nuclea con una
visión y a través de una panoplia de
medidas muy positivas les quiero
preguntar porque seguramente nuestros
espectadores están preguntando ya todo
esto los organismos internacionales que
es decir tienen la obligación de
redoblar la vigilancia las sanciones
hasta qué punto son efectivas pintan
algo los organismos internacionales en
estos casos nada siquiera bueno a mí me
parece que actualmente hay un una suerte
de conflictividad entre amd entre claro
la oea y la celac porque obviamente la
oea tiene cierta tendencia pero
estadounidense y recientemente han
expresado su preocupación por el
debilitamiento de los pesos y
contrapesos que están pasando en el
salvador y por otro lado la celac si la
semana pasada se realizó la cumbre de
altos
de altos mandos y en donde él preside
fue justamente el vicepresidente del
salvador representando a su país félix
ulloa diciendo que la celac puede
también ser un mecanismo alternativo de
toma de decisiones entonces me parece
que a nivel internacional está bastante
también conflictuada la situación algo
más que ver
no lamentablemente no hay tampoco una
integración latinoamericana ahora la
celac no tiene nuestro peso la oea está
efectivamente bastante deslegitimizado
porque se ve como un instrumento de
injerencia estadounidense entonces es
complicado en ese sentido que los
organismos internacionales puedan tener
un peso y la
estrategia de eeuu de ayudar a la lucha
anticorrupción por ahora no ha surtido
efecto se vea la reacción de buque le
esté a las críticas de derivas
autoritarias en cambio su twitter este y
se auto definió como el dictador este
más cool del mundo mundial lo sea
literalmente o sea que por ahora la
estrategia de eeuu no tiene mucho efecto
y a todo esto los jóvenes me no me
gustaría acabar sin nombrar sin nombrar
los que son mayoría en la población
joven que es mayoritaria está llamada a
hacerse cargo sin demora de revisar el
pasado que tan implicados verán los
jóvenes de la región con el futuro de
centroamérica igualmente depende de los
países en nicaragua sufrieron
físicamente cuál fue la mayoría de los
muertos en las manifestaciones de 1819
los jóvenes en el salvador se
movilizaron para el buque
definitivamente esperando un nuevo
porvenir y porvenir también depende
porque eso es la complejidad de
centroamérica es la razón por la cual la
integración es muy importante pero
también diría
rápidamente que por cierto vamos a
conflictos a conflictos activos eso no
lo dudemos por supuesto la presión
internacional es muy importante pero la
diversidad internacional provoca hoy en
día un esa forma de relativismo y de
nueva oportunidad para los dejamos
porque me quedo sin tiempo para más
muchísimas gracias angelina maria jose
pascal y a todos ustedes hasta la
próxima semana que en primera plana
gracias
ah
[Música]